I'm gonna try to join weights game here
oh my god I just went in on my life oh
boy
howdy oh hi alright okay I got where are
you guys white like grayscale when I'm
like inside boy me like ripoff Bennett
foggy vibes oh ho this is such a ripoff
of Bennett body all right I can already
tell him and I hate this
well you made progress I'm not making
progress I wish I could get back down to
you guys I can't get back over the
banana oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay so we do a full flip in the air
without touching anything you get a
bigger boost on the jump Oh zing things
that we had to learn slowly over time oh
that helps
okay yeah you can't touch anything okay
why do you always this next section
sucks hmm okay guys did we win oh my god
how do you oh there's a banana in the
air Oh pick it up on the top and Anna
and then boost off of it I think Frick
oh my god Wade this is the worst it's
funny okay
why are there levels you might level up
your character or something I'm not good
at this but I like this and you know I
kind of liked Bennet foggy at first too
but I feel like I just found so far away
oh wait oh man oh god oh god I just
and a half that we're at right now mark
wait where are we supposed to go we're
supposed to go up I want to see it so
bad I just I can't do I can't do floaty
controls guys I just can't I did it
that's great no oh my god screw this
noise
nonsense wait did I just can't do floaty
controls
I need my controls to be nice and
precise and fordable floating floating
oh my god I'm gonna die all backwards
that's the way there's a reason I
stopped playing rage games is because I
have a visceral reaction to like
controls that I don't like I just will
not relax he'll get I will be good at
this because getting good at you're only
saying that cuz you know it'll make me
matter I'm back up here I didn't take
two hours like last time I didn't see
[ __ ] wait you didn't I got a pause for a
second I'm just oh yes hey thank you
thank you
perfect chick-fil-a time thank you lunch
I got some chick-fil-a oh just take a
little breather in 30 seconds
I don't care what Wade is accomplishing
I have what I need right here so I just
got this as far as I got in two hours I
just reached get further up there
becomes wind oh no what mark
what take you back I love this game it's
fine everything's fine no no no I'm not
cheating I'm just you paused yeah I'm
reading the controls okay you're fakie
why does your finger hurt what are you
talking about button too hard because
he's oh you're playing on controller
yeah yeah it's a controller is easier ah
god damn it it's oh hey well I'm
starting to get a feel of it what did I
just get the worst is when you bounce up
somewhere and then you know you're sick
lands on it and yeah I swear I was
getting bigger boost jumps before oh my
god the Flies why do the Flies exist
that's the water mmm
wait I'm so glad you're having fun up
there oh there's a bit okay so you got
to hold it down like all the way you
mean you have to hold it down like all
the way you don't have to let go of it
is what I'm saying oh it's so much
better if you just hold down space the
whole time it's so much better it's like
infinitely better chill kid chill who's
what who's kid me I don't work
concerning me I don't know my boots seem
to be working good oh my god that was
like the superest boost ever
jump so high oh my god I can't I can't
with this I literally I can't
it makes no sense the inconsistency of
the power yeah the power seems crazy to
me I don't I'm not Auto percent sure
what the deal is with the power flip
jumpy oh my god the whole the whole wall
jumping concept but see oh my god it's
okay
mark it's fine oh [ __ ] yes wait I didn't
do it I have a [ __ ] I'm angry sad
because I wanted to succeed I know I I
thought I was done I [ __ ] up I think I
could have made it if I understood what
was happening I do feel like I'm getting
better though like this feels like it
might actually be what someone just came
tumbling down by me all right so leave
is this game hackable are we about to
get [ __ ] hackers in here well there's
there's somebody [ __ ] all right oh yeah
oh my god oh my god oh my god stop
jumping off of the walls oh my god
you can't stop jumping interesting I
just I need them I need a moment you
need a moment hi you need a moment I've
got nice nice sandwiches that are just
going nice and cold well I'm trying to
oh my god stop jumping up the wall I'm
so happy that it's not me down there for
once it's just if it would stay it do
why is it with JP we're in a better
place
why does it do that oh is it because I'm
holding down space oh that makes sense
no no god oh my god I swear I swear - I
swear - [ __ ] I swear to [ __ ] just be
[Laughter]
played this oh oh oh my god oh it's so
hard to just get it in to where I need
it to be there we go yes okay I'm here
I'm gonna stop okay here we go and oh
stop stop moving oh my god why did I did
the biggest super jump I've ever done in
my existence oh my god okay I know how
to do this I know
okay everything's fine here's the hill
with the window yes oh my god okay my
friend is here
no wait how's it going where's mark I
got min I'm coming I [ __ ] Oh Laxus
game you guys like this game I love this
game hey dr. Pope is over here whoever
the [ __ ] that is
I don't know dr. Pope I almost dr.
pepper day I heard that name though
[ __ ] [ __ ] go away hey Marco you sound
different
why would I sound different so same old
me know what mark I feel your pain you
know dude don't
my pain oh [ __ ] if you can't say that
with the mouthful of chick-fil-a I just
I'm getting better is the thing I'm
getting better at it
yeah I mean I spent literally two hours
we recorded for over two hours you
really don't get past this where where
did you get to I guess where you just
saw pee really yes isn't that hard
i I found the heck I'm a hacker I'm the
best okay I found the way I'm gonna get
up this mountain through unbelievable
pro skills okay that's really difficult
to do I'm not gonna try to do that when
I can't even do the basic way are there
more flies hears birds no I mean I'm
saying
are there more flies here where I am it
feels like there's more okay here we go
do your clothes and stuff you know what
my controller's dying go [ __ ] yes I'm
switching a mouse and keyboard oh you
both on controller get in the hole oh
I'm in a new area I've never been here
before yes yes yes guys guys guys guys
did what everyone else did thank you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I got it oh come on the
slipping is really unnecessary it's such
a narrow angle that you have to set
goddamnit oh not oh no okay no why would
you grab there Oh Bob I might kill my
own I might kill Oh mark calm down
everything's fine it's working
[ __ ] you found your secret mantra [ __ ]
calm down it's working everything's fine
it's really difficult up here as well
let you know where are you and why don't
I care good it's fine this is uncharted
territory for me what Bob Bob shut up
don't use me for your monster you're
stealing my skill hey everything I keep
slapping my stupid round body where it
doesn't deserve to be so not like it oh
oh oh oh I knew that was a dumb sombrero
sombrero guys that's great yeah yeah
that's cool so proud of you oh it's the
wind there's wind wind there's clearly
wind up here please pull go to the right
please God it's fine it's fine it's fine
no God why would you do that that makes
no sense
oh no no no no no don't be like Mark
don't be what are you talking about what
are people saying about me huh I'm not
no one's saying anything yeah no no mark
down like mark and shut your trap I
swear
I swear I don't care what you think of
me just it better be yes yes yes I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make wiser winks
why is there some wind I'm not gonna
make it you fool I feel like the wind is
inconsistent I just want to say that
straight up you have to jump it like a
really sharp angle to like avoid the
wind wait I just realized I didn't want
your advice
I concur I'm offended that you thought I
needed your help
who's in the same place is me you so how
does that feel
this is not me wow you're into the top
mark I've seen the golden the promised
land you have not you have not you have
not no one no one has I I have it's
golden no one has no one has no one no
one has it all I can't get I can't get
these people and why aren't they you too
I can't get a steep angle cuz my stupid
round body hits the thing and therefore
I don't get I can't I can't do it's
impossible to do a steep angle it just
is oh my oh my god oh my god
it's just it's definitely not impossible
ok so just it is so unbelievably
impossible oh my god really oh well
you're keeping it together mark if I be
quiet
I feel the path if I am loud the path
eludes me well I think I see the path
feel to you that also is true oh my
gotten out there I go [ __ ] every god
I'm oh man what have I done mark you see
where I am no I don't Oh God Oh
careful Baha Oh God okay oh no I was the
hair bob once I reached my apex kill yo
[ __ ] me you're gonna see gameplay
[Laughter]
gameplay the likes of which you've never
seen
yes yes yes
what is this what this is not the top
the top what no no no not like this now
like this ho boy here we go power blast
like that I'm better than you I think
maybe yours is just uh okay I'm at the
boost effect of hearts you've got the
explosion that's why it's all the same
unit here we go visit I'm up out of here
oh [ __ ] me well it's good to see you
dude hey bud how you been nope oh god no
no not like this
I am so close oh it's not falling over
you little you little [ __ ] you okay why
are you kidding me no oh my god hating
everything about this entire game yes
yes yes okay I'm here my skill is too
many people here oh my god oh my god
there goes my momentum
no I'm not where's the top I don't know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but not that bad here we go back to a
controller the controller is so much
better no I'm making the keyboard work
for me you know what I mean just take a
break
hey I hate this so much guys I can't
describe my hate for this I've got a
controller
I'm ready did you both get out of here
while I was [ __ ] around no yeah oh
wait what all right I'm not back down so
I'm I'm the best if I could stop I mean
I know why it's happening but I refuse
to let go of the spacebar because of
principles that I have sure sure yeah I
have principles unlike a certain freshly
shaven man I will not let go of the
spacebar I just won't
[Applause]
don't you're not boss now if you're
still down there oh stop are you on top
right now [ __ ] try not to lose it yes
I am but also I'm trying to progress
because I'm skilled I it's not just a
constant fight to not lose it's a
constant fight for victory here we go
in it to win it is the wrong way to go
Oh God okay oh my god oh my god oh my oh
my oh my I swear I swear there we go
I'm up oh my god well I'm back down
again well I'm up oh my god I forgot
that you get super Oh God
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]